[Musica]
non so che cosa cazzo sto facendo ma
questa musica è troppo [ __ ] terra tutti
ragazzi e benvenuti questo nuovo video
sono fa vigenti ed oggi siamo sui verbis
virtus ragazzi è passato più di un anno
da quando ho fatto la demo di in
vervisch virtus è veramente è stata una
delle demo che mi è piaciuta di più in
assoluto di qualsiasi gioco io abbia mai
provato perché praticamente i ragazzi
sto gioco si lanciano le magie con la
voce vera cioè prima che usi microfono
per per lanciare magie e la cosa è
esageratamente [ __ ] e comunque ragazzi
sono veramente fiero di poter giocare un
gioco del genere perché è sviluppato
completamente da italiani quindi ragazzi
un gioco italiano al cento per cento dei
ragazzi direi di cominciare perché vi
veramente sono non sto più nella pelle
per poterci giocare perché lo sto
aspettando praticamente da troppo
ragazzi sto gioco e non vedo l'ora di
giocarci ma quindi iniziamo
immediatamente dove cazzo se ha già la
partenza è bellissima siamo in mezzo al
deserto che il cio è mica l'abbiamo noi
che è iniziato già c'è una bufera la
madonna era l
ma se tu guardi il meteo prima di uscire
non ci sono questi problemi amico dove
cazzo siamo dato perché ciò sto quanto
staff it non lo voglio anch'io so quanto
subito
c'è veramente figo ragazzi quel coso ho
visto sui bei lo vendevano 10 dollari no
no no perfetto non ne conoscevano visto
dove siamo
sì ma zio usa un cazzo di tomtom per
favore non devi finire per far east i
posti dove non si sa come ci sei
arrivato amico mio va beh io sono
disperso nelle nei deserti del mondo non
so perché sta svendendo ragazzi che
cazzo sono da che sono anche svenuto
bellissimi inverni sperto ragazzi storia
di un ubriaco che si è ritrovato nel
deserto a caso meraviglioso ragazzi un
giorno che ti spiega finalmente come ci
siamo finiti al punto di partenza per il
reperimento ha perso il tom tom che
processerà ubriacato la sera prima
cercava di tornare a casa e siamo finiti
qui poche parole nuovi il mouse per
guardarti intorno ai tossivo st per
camminare perfetto ragazzi questo era lì
era l'inizio della demo mi pare non
vorrei dire un no vorrei fare un film ma
mi pare che la diamo fosse così per
quanto mi ricordi
allora dobbiamo andare prendi spazio
passate al seno mi ricordo i comandi
lega quindi fatemi fare di nuovo
perfetto e cosa bella ragazze che non mi
ricordo un cap cioè permettere avevo
giocato un anno fa ma non mi ricordo
niente anche se sta parte l'ho fatta
sì questo è ok ragazzi il tempio di zeus
non so perché è spuntato non so perché
ci sia una cosa del genere in mezzo ai
deserti desolati ma non importa noi
entriamo per esaminare l'iscrizione
osserva nella vicina premier o che
questa cosa me la ricordavo la devo
andare vicino a sti cosi e prendere è
perché così si aprono che poi dall'altro
ragazzi ma che cazzo di porte forma non
potevano fare una porta normale
all'altezza uomo no perché questi passa
un carro armato
vabbè comunque ragazzi per aprirsi cose
dovrei ecco lo ricordavo premere è su
sti cosi non chiedetevi perché i ragazzi
perché perché credo sia un nuovo tipo di
di pulsante c'è invece di accendere le
luci lega nel futuro ci avremmo sti cosi
ovviamente dobbiamo dobbiamo pigiare
sulle tavole così almeno si accende la
luce in poche parole è l'ultima questa
terra qui vero si perse o che non ho
ecco i sei aperto la porta ragazzi fatti
bossari carri armati è nata non c'è neve
ragazzi a coloro capito perché un uomo
dovrebbe entrare in una caverna che sta
sotto design hood che sa in un tempio in
un deserto
va beh la cosa bellissima e che non
nostra parte non c'era
cioè io io io avevo giocato a tutt'altra
cosa non mi pare che ci fosse stata
parte va beh non importa ok sono caduto
dal mezzo chilometro di altezza ma non
fa niente
va bè ragazzi evito di farmi domande
perché ho capito le prime ne faccio è
peggio air dove cazzo ne andare di qua
come disse portare il tom tom era più
facile è tutta colpa storica se non
perdeva il tuo nome non è no mista
situazione di merda non sono sto andando
però non è ok
rega che cazzo è stato oggi è perfetto
siamo al cospetto di qualche dio del
deserto chiamò che cos'è stokr
matematica ci rincontriamo ma vabbè
ragazzi questo è arabo kick ass
hai appena imparato d'incantesimo la
formula è stata inserita nel diario
lancia un incantesimo ti è venuto dal
sinistro del mouse e pronuncia la
formula poi di darsi al tasto per intero
per incantesimo premi il tasto destro
ragazzi ce l'abbiamo un incantesimo che
non so quale cazzo si sa però cielo
premo j luce sia troppo a ragazzo che ho
cambiato un attimo cosa delle magie ho
messo quello in inglese perché avevo
pronunciarla di nuovo perché è stato il
momento più bello della mia vita quindi
devo rifarlo ragazzi state per assistere
ad una delle cose più [ __ ] della storia
se le pronte let there be light se
funziona perché non vedono o perso metà
vita quasi dalton avevo visto che cazzo
è regala devo devo andare avanti di qui
perfetto dalla siamo dovesse dove siamo
carriera di merda vabbè non sono
allenato scusatevi un perfetto regalo
non so perché ci sono sti cosi non
chiedetemelo ma è difficile più
difficile di quanto pensassimo aspettare
un attimo
ok ok che bel madonna che possono
turchia [ __ ] che figo c'è una cosa o
dio mio che c'è ragazzi per aver
terminato la pizza ai funghi ma vabbè st
cos'è beli cosa sono sti cosi a terre
non vedo un cut e lunedì al gra grazie
no perché non vedeva una mazza è una
cosa così è una
il tuo diario è stato aggiornato cos'è
ho preso altra magia la teologia ragazzi
l'osservatore l'occhio della trinità che
osservano tu non devi ricambiare è un
documento volevo una magia non c'è non
c'era un magie nuove lume me si sa se ho
capito però me ne serve un amico a ecco
perfetto ci siamo dove stiamo andando di
preciso ma che cazzo è sta roba che
ragazze più è più grosso della ocean c'è
una cosa o mio dio
ok va bene facciamo finta linguetta ci
sono posti troppo belli se non ho capito
perché ci sono sti posti pazzeschi da
dove sbucano fuori non lo so ragazzi
siamo piano terra grazie rischiamo un
ascensore di nuova generazione no perché
non sa neanche se non ai cavi bellissimo
se vedete per tecnologia non so perché
questo c'è una c'è un anello a nonno è
perfetto ma cosa me la ricordo ragazzi e
meraviglioso sto posto anche se non so
che cazzo serve anche perché come magia
ci sono lunghe e più alla è troppo bello
dirlo è troppo bello o mi date una magia
o sfondo tutto giura vedere esperia
harmos lo metti al lume di all ok non
devi dirlo con convinzione o non
funziona ragazzi di voi che cosa cazzo è
quel coso ragazzino mi chiamo vede un
cast nome ti al rumaithy al lume e al
nome di all
grazie
i ragazzi non vedevano una mazza
purtroppo perché allora fermi un attimo
ok ok perche no
perfetto sì sì dio mio che si è finiti
legali chi è questa la stanza dello
spirito del tempo di dragon ball
c'è un altro incantesimo risotto poi non
usano gli ascensori usano ste cose che
fa molto più figo cioè nel senso sono
molto più tecnologici bellissimo grazie
grazie molto gentili che posso dire
grazie mille ok eccolo lì a chi l'ha
fatto ragazzi grazie però spesso molto
gentili il tuo diario il salto giornata
cos'è sta roba spurs raggio di luce
ecco lume lume e belli eccolo caronda
energetica anno la band più o meno
volume no cos'è sta roba
ok ragazzi qualcuno mi dica cosa succede
a ok sta andando devo andare lì sotto
che ci sia ragazzi ho visto un passaggio
qui sotto devo passare di qua c'è di
usare la magia per andare avanti è
bellissimo ragazzo vado vado vado qui a
ieri assalto alla in bilico ci sono di
fatto non so come matti non vedo un
cazzo nome di allah
lunedì al lume di all ok perfetto che
qua ce n'è una ragazzi c'è un altro
incantesimo da usare che non ho ancora
che dovrei andare a prendere dove dove
c'era la gemma praticamente ci devo
tornare fin lì
eccoci qua michea mezz'ora non mi
ricordo più incantesimi amazon dettagli
va beh come cazzo si dice mi ricordo più
porca [ __ ] mini cordata è a tulum è
perfetto che culo è andato a culo perché
veramente amico dopo una mazza perfetto
cosa devo fare qui
questo questo volevo puntare legate non
mi ricordo che credo sia questo che
perfetto che non si sia prendere ga
rimangono così nel dubbio però la rumore
pare di sì ecco perfetto mick jagger che
però aveva altro altro che che
scassinatori forte è una casa dove siamo
perché non vedo un cazzo costante io
vado di qua mi piace andare di sopra
perché lì sotto ci siamo già dati fin
troppo ma io vado di so ragazzi ma che
si intravede qualcosa ma non si capisce
cosa gesù sei tu
era che non vece vedo una luce però non
sto ancora morendo quindi mi fa strano
comunque io torno indietro che la solita
sfiga rega ci abbiate pazienza
cos'è che sarà a nonna lanterne chicca
scende lanterne in un posto così
ditemelo
non ha senso non impone andiamo avanti
stavo cascando in modo bruttissimo ok ok
non so dove siamo ma la cosa non mi
piace per niente
ci sono delle colonne secolo è questa
sia per tutta con la stessa macchina
markoff command marchio del comando ma
non c'è la delega direi che posso
concludere più il primo episodio dal
avrei fatto molto più lungo di così è
però il problema è che non so non so
cosa cazzo devo fare mezz'ora in giro
mentre continua il prossimo episodio
quando trova appunto la magia per
sollevare le cose perché una cosa è
fattibile e quindi niente ragazzi come
al solito servito è piaciuto lo stato
come se mi piace anche al progetto di
facebook e con ogni video tratta nella
descrizione sarà sede per i siti
scrivete noi ci vediamo al prossimo vito
le ragazze